what is up everybody it's a nematic and
welcome to another episode of anime ASMR
anime we expect anime videos yeah that's
it the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments this
week we finally found out the winner for
best anime in the crunchy roll anime
awards and to no one's surprise the
winner was Yuri on ice yet again now
already said a bunch of all these awards
I don't want to get into it too much but
I did find a great video the other day
by a youtuber called divx i believe
thats how she pronounces it and this
video is called we need to talk about
Yuri on ice I really liked this video
because divx is herself a big urea nice
fan and she's a member of a bunch of
United fan communities but she had a
whole bunch of things to say about these
awards she was not happy at all and
let's listen to some of the things she
said why she thinks that you realized
one all these awards even though it did
not deserve to win all of them I know
exactly how you're a nice one of these
things all your little fan girls in our
fandom spans the [ __ ] out of tumblr
facebook twitter i'm in to Yuri on ice
groups that has thousands and thousands
of members in it on facebook and you all
just spans the [ __ ] out of the crunchy
roll awards we're like full for here a
nice for all of these things just do it
goes over like y'all just needs took
over no wonder you're a nice [ __ ] won
everything it wasn't even like a thing
where it was just genuinely an all-over
amazing anime and everyone in the
animated community just loved it so much
it was just all of the fans spamming the
[ __ ] out of everyone to go vote for your
eyes and I saw some people even make
extra account takeover what that's
insane insane indeed like I said I
really like this video if you want to
learn more about this whole thing be
sure to check out the full video the
link is in the description and she goes
step by step and breaks down all the
different award categories and what she
thinks you're you should have won and
shouldn't have won and why so it's
definitely a great video check it out
ian is that these fans of urea Knights
who went too far and started spamming
four votes voting for your Ian's eyes no
matter what using fake accounts actually
did a disservice to the anime they love
I'm assuming that they wanted to bring
more attention to it and get more people
to watch it but now what they actually
did was make you realize one of the most
overrated and let's just say it's
frankly hated anime of 2016 because of
what happened not only did these fan
tactics make a joke out of the crunchy
roll anime awards but no one is really
talking about the actual quality of urea
nice now everyone is just talking about
the fans what the fans did how the show
is overrated how won a bunch of boards
it shouldn't have and so on so instead
of talking about the actual merits of
the show we've generated into a sort of
hate mob everyone hates each other once
I'd hate you realized it's overrated it
sucks because of the fans the fans of
your night everyone was hitting on them
back and all this kind of stuff so
that's not me I think there's a lesson
to be learned here by all fan bases be
fair be correct and don't resort to
these tactics it's really not cool
people will resent you and you will get
the opposite effect of what you want it
the second topic that I want to talk
about is the confusion around the seven
deadly sin season two announcement so
basically what happened was Netflix
released their new release is scheduled
for februari and on februari 17th we see
that they're scheduled to release seven
deadly sins season two now this was
reported widely in a bunch of media
sources that season two is coming out
however the problem is that no one knows
about this season two and it looks like
by most reliable sources are reporting
that by season two netflix really means
these four episode ova signs of a holy
war which actually aired back in August
in Japan now unfortunately even though I
really want to see them to it makes a
lot more sense that this is just the OVA
because it would be unprecedented for
netflix to release an anime series that
no one knew about right on netflix
before it ever airs in japan and it's
like a big huge secret and then it just
comes out a month earlier we find out
the season is all ready to go so I'm
afraid that this is just the OVA that we
are being misled when they say season
two
and that we're going to be disappointed
even though I really want to see season
two as soon as possible I hope we hear
something more specific and more
definitive soon and if you'd like to
check out everything we know so far
about the seven deadly sin season two
you can check out the video i made on
that subject a few weeks ago the link is
in the description the new Dragon Ball
super universe survival arc promo or
promotional video PV came out a few days
ago and my brother goes and who follows
dragon ball super made a video analyzing
this PV this you teaser trailer sort of
thing so if you're interested in Dragon
Ball super i will leave the link in the
description to that video i personally
don't follow Dragon Ball super but goes
and definitely does so that's something
you're interested in you will have some
videos coming out by goals and soon also
on this channel I created what I
consider to be the ultimate code geass
waifu quiz so if you want to know who
your ideal code geass wife who is be
sure to check out the video and you can
take the quiz yourself along with us
this video is basically goes and trying
to be honest and take the quiz and still
get a call in who is his preferred waifu
so if you want to see what happened and
who goes and really got be sure to check
out the video link in the description
Joey Danny my man just arrived in las
vegas where he is visiting his real-life
wife who aki dearest where I think about
a month or so this is cool news I'm sure
they're going to make some really
interesting videos together and just
look at this picture of them when they
met up at the airport I mean how cute
are these guys forget the anime Awards
most heartwarming moment right here now
there are a few members of our anime up
for community that are big one piece
fans and I will name any names aha
Briggs from old anime and creep Ellen
but they have been complaining that we
don't include enough one piece content
on this channel so in their honor for
this week's and V I am featuring an Andy
called broken by a youtuber named Rock
AMV this one piece amv is awesome I
really like the music i love how it goes
with the visuals and i just thoroughly
enjoyed this amv be sure to check it out
and that's it for this week guys if you
enjoyed these videos be sure to like
subscribe and nominate me for a crunchy
roll anime award and until next time see
ya space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]